hey youtubers is Charlie so they got a
Justice League dark live-action film in
production this is gonna be a breakdown
of what's going on the characters that
they're going with in just a reminder
about the animated Justice League dark
that's coming up too so most of you
probably have a vague idea of what
Justice League dark is it's basically
like a Justice League for magic users
when they did flashpoint like the big
flashpoint event the new 52 came along
they rebooted the team swapped old
characters out new characters in and
part of the initial storyline was to
explain why exactly you needed a magical
Justice League when you had the real
Justice League with Superman Wonder
Woman Batman and all the other
characters like if they're badasses why
do you need a Justice League dark well
enchantress basically hands the Justice
League their asses so everyone decides
hey we need a group of magical
specialists to handle threats like this
so that creates the need for Justice
League dark and what just happened in
the DC movies we had Suicide Squad where
we saw a bunch of magic things going on
in Chandra is possessed by the succubus
almost took over the earth so naturally
you can see the end for the Justice
League movie where they're supposed to
be like the way Geoff Johns and the
other people they're talking about it
it's going to be deeply integrated with
the movie universe so they look at
threats like they had in Suicide Squad
oh my god we have big magical villains
we need magical heroes to help fight
them so right now this will get you
really excited the team that they're
talking about is supposed to be in the
movie this could change a little bit
they could swap a couple characters but
for now the team is Constantine Swamp
Thing and everyone's really excited
about that dead man
Zatanna and eat Rogen the demon so even
though a lot of these characters have
been around in the comics for a long
time the idea of the Justice League dark
team working together is relatively
recent like in the last 10 years or so
so it's not like you have to go back to
the 1950s to start reading backstory but
you can see how the movies are trying to
include as many of people's favorite
characters as possible like they want
people to understand who some of them
are before you go see this so everyone
has a pretty good idea of who most of
these characters are do you know dead
man isn't relatively well known outside
of the comic book universe but that's
okay they'll explain their backstories
the same way that explained the Suicide
Squad characters because like most
people know who Killer Croc is but
everyone's like who's Slipknot who's
this character you know like there's
gonna be a couple characters that you'll
have to get to know through the course
of the film but I'm hoping because they
haven't really done any Teen Titans
stuff yet is that they'll do Raven at
some point either she'll swap for
enchantress in Suicide Squad and be like
a backdoor to Trigon but Trigon would be
a villain that the Justice League dark
would go up against they've been known
to work with Argus so they'll be
interacting with Amanda Waller like
they'd probably learn about the threats
through her the house of mystery is
their base of operation the house itself
is kind of like a Room of Requirement
where you know it changes shape and size
just depending on what people need it
for but I would expect them to do a lot
of deep cuts from the comics a lot of
really fun stuff so we met in Qian trous
in in the movie universe she's kind of
from the nightshade realm which is an
alternate dimension Constantine brings
in the idea of a heaven and hell God
angels demons the devil then you have a
bunch of different types of magic that
the different members of the team
practice like you have Zatanna that
speaks magical spells backwards so I
know it sounds a little confusing
especially if you're not super familiar
with the comics what the movies gonna do
is just like find a really creative way
to simplify all that make it easy to
understand because if they want as many
people to go see this as possible so in
the way Suicide Squad drew on a lot of
really deep cuts from the Suicide Squad
comics narrative problems aside most of
you that went to see that movie could
probably understand what was going on
with each of the characters even though
they didn't really over explain the
magical elements and I do have to say
I'm kind of bummed that Guillermo del
Toro isn't working on this anymore
he was trying to get a Justice League
dark movie made for a long time like
when you hear about george miller's
version of Justice League or Kevin Smith
version of Superman like all those
different scripts that were happening in
the last like 10 to 15 years they never
got made projects that never came to
fruition that was around the time he
airmailed del Toro was trying to get a
Justice League dark movie off the ground
but I would expect the way it looks like
the magic the special effects to be in
keeping with the other Justice League
movies that we've seen so far
like Batman V Superman Suicide Squad so
while like the visual effects will look
relatively similar
expect the movie to carry its own tone
it'll have its own sense of humor it's
not gonna be a carbon copy of like the
Batman Justice League movie just with
magical characters each of the
characters that they picked to put in
the team drive the tone of the film so a
lot of it will flow from that and that's
really where Jeff Jones comes in he's
like the guy who like who goes to really
good directors who might not know a lot
about comics but make really awesome
films and says okay
these are who these characters are this
is their motivation this is kind of the
tone of their character so while he's
definitely co-writing the Batman movie
with Ben Affleck the Batman solo film
he's also probably going to be working
on the scripts for some of these other
movies too like he is actually a
credited co-writer on the Wonder Woman
script which is why I'm really excited
like I can't wait to see Wonder Woman
just because it's the beginning of the
Jeff Jones era of the DC movies some of
you may have seen around comic-con there
was a trailer for the animated Justice
League that is going to be dropping
later this year
now that is separate from the
live-action Justice League dark that
I've been talking about in this video
but if you want a good primer for
Justice League dart watch the animated
movie it should be a lot of fun and they
even got matt ryan from the air overs to
voice the constantine role it's the
magic of the house decided it wanted to
experience humanity and gave itself a
body we also have black orchid who is a
manifestation of the house which is
different than it's been in the comics
your life is a patchwork of blackness
was no time for joy how do you cope with
it I have a butler
no two ways about it we need to get
close to have a chance
I expect the worst so I prepare for the
worst we were able to line up Matt Ryan
who played Constantine on TV he really
was Constantine to me I really wanted to
jump into this project to play
Constantine in a different context
around some of the iconic characters
there in the DC dark world
Alec Allen was murdered by terrorists
his body was never recovered innocent
lives are at stake I think it's one of
the best Justice sig scripts so far do
you see why I can't do what you do she
always has to say how she feels in the
situation I could kill him little late
for that my friend sweet that means her
to me why are we in the middle of a
godforsaken swamp to smash your skull is
what I crave it's a different kind of
story than what we've done in the past
with just fighting aliens or fighting
Lex Luthor or supervillains but now
we're dealing with you know villains who
want to take your soul I think fans can
expect the unexpected don't consider the
cost now John there's no time here's
what real magic looks like Arnaud
reaction move fine and dandy let's take
a walk on the dark side then I know a
lot of you would like to see Matt Ryan
be in the movie universe I have no idea
who they would cast but they might wind
up going with Colin Farrell or like a
bigger name just don't be surprised if
they don't cast Matt Ryan but it's
totally possible well let me know in the
comments like what do you want them to
do with Justice League dark there's so
many different directions that they
could go they just we haven't really
done a lot of magical stuff in the DC
movies and now it's going from like zero
to amazing weirdness overnight it's
gonna be so much fun I know I just did
that guardians of the galaxy video where
I talk about how Marvel phase 3 is going
like maximum tentacle I have a fever and
the only prescription is more tentacles
and now Marvel has hired Dan Harmon to
punch up Doctor Strange so he's just
gonna Cronenberg the out of that
movie and if you don't know what that
means Dan Harmon is just the person who
writes all of Rick and Morty which is
one of the best new cartoon series so if
you haven't seen
go check it out but it just means that
all the comic book movies Marvel in DC
are getting way weirder in the best
possible way so what's gonna happen is
is I'll do more Justice League dark as
they announce people like those start
casting people eventually they have to
hire a writer first they haven't written
the movie yet I'm expecting it probably
won't drop till 2018 2019 at the
earliest so we probably won't even see
the first teaser at least until like the
beginning of 2018 they're still filming
the regular Justice League so I mean
it's gonna take them a while to finish
that but I am expecting some more
teasers towards the end of the year
we'll probably get a Super Bowl trailer
it's actually gonna be really good for
Super Bowl trailers next year because we
have spider-man Home Coming guardians of
the galaxy to Wonder Woman and Thor
Ragnarok so there's gonna be so much
stuff dropping in the next six months
it's gonna be so awesome and that's just
the movies I'm not even talking about
the comic book TV shows
speaking of Thor stuff over in the
Marvel Universe there was this picture
of homeless Odin that drop so I'll be
doing a video for that there's a new
arrow season 5 trailer so I'll try to
get those videos out as fast as possible
but there is a new round of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so whole bunch of awesome stuff
dropped today I'll try to get through it
as fast as possible what do you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the new flash trailer I just posted
and you can click here to learn more
about the black flash called the rival
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight